إذا دمرت جيلًا كاملاً من
ثقافة الناس ، فستقول إنهم لم يكونوا موجودين أبدًا ،
فهذا ما يريده هتلر ،
ففكر في ذلك ، دعنا نذهب إلى اللون الأسود
، لقد أبلغت عن نبي يونجس في
الناصرة ، يشاع أنه يصنع معجزات
تقول إن العاهرات يصلين له
وسيستمع  الشرطة هنا تخبرهم
بأنني سأكون على حق
، لقد قُتلت وتعتقد أنني فعلت
ذلك ، عليك أن تختبئ أو لم
يتوقعوا أبدًا أن يجدوك
مرحبًا بك في الظلام ، سوف يسجل اسمي
في التاريخ باعتباره أعظم منحدر للجميع
الوقت
الذي تقصد فيه أسماءنا ، بالطبع ،
اسمي أولاً ثم spacebar spacebar ،
اسمك قادم أب عظيم ،
نقوم ببناء سفينة للنجاة من
العاصفة ،
يأخذ الدرع nog العالم لأنه ليس كما
نود أن يكون هذا ليس  الحرية ،
هذا خوف يمكننا حرفياً أن نغير
العالم ، فماذا عن بيتر ليس لدى كل شخص
نهاية سعيدة ، أعرف من أنت ،
لست خائفًا ، أعتقد أنني في الخارج ،
فستكون خائفًا